il ya les parties ont aussi leur
existence il ya toujours des craintes
mais là en réalité c'est cette une est
un compromis qui s'est construit un
compromis chacun doit faire des efforts
de son côté parfois d'autres un peu plus
que d'autres mais ça si bas c'est donc
au parti si je sais qu'on a l'art du
compromis pour le coup et on a essayé de
malheureusement plus tôt on n'est pas
dans la gérer la force qui a qui a
organisé ça cette fois ci mais en tout
cas on ya participé on peut être fier de
nous d'avoir construit ce set ce nouveau
cette nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale qui est en attente
attendu pardon par les électeurs de
gauche une dernière question parti
socialiste y en a plein qui sont pas
d'accord
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez est ce
que vous pensez comment penser que ça va
se passer aux bureaux nationaux conseil
national ça sera ça sera très compliqué
très compliqué parce que
moi j'ai vous savez j'ai fait partie
d'une génération qui a qui a vu la fin
du quinquennat de hollande et 10 en fin
j'ai envie de vous dire dix ans après
donc en 2012 à 2022 j'ai vu plutôt un
parti qui
a subi de beaucoup plus de défaites que
de victoires en réalité et un
effondrement à la fois dans sa base
militante et
dans ses élus et donc du coup je me
rends compte que il faut passer par des
choses parfois douloureuse il faut se
faire faut se faire mal parfois pour
reconstruire notamment un peut-être un
quelque chose qui pourrait incarner un
réformisme radical écologique et sociale
on aura vous savez dans un collectif en
tout cas moi je me mets à la place d'un
électeur de gauche qui va voir qui est
un collectif qui s'est construit il y
aura les bons joueurs et les mauvais
joueurs et bah faisons partie des bons
joueurs
[Musique]